these days a hit movie getting a sequel
isn't much of a surprise in fact it's
usually a given
nonetheless there are a few projects in
the work that nobody
could possibly have seen coming here are
the sequels you probably had
no idea were even happening it's been
almost
20 years since audiences first followed
sorority girl l
woods to harvard law school in the
bubblegum comedy legally blonde
the movie was followed up with 2003's
legally blonde 2 red white and blonde
and now l is back in an as yet untitled
three-quarter
not much has been said in the way of
plot details although sources originally
told deadline that the third movie will
be much in the spirit of the first film
which saw elle draw on her fashion sense
optimism and strong sense of sisterhood
to define the patriarchy
lift up the women around her and look
great doing it
you got into harvard law
[Music]
what like it's hard that deadline report
mostly referred to an earlier draft of
the script before office alum mindy
kaling and brooklyn 99 creator dan gore
took over writing duties
but it's easy to imagine that the new
story will also embrace the original
movie's themes of female empowerment
legally blonde 3 is expected to arrive
in may 2022
when the meg first swam into theaters
plenty of people were skeptical at what
appeared to be an over-the-top
jaws rip-off but this megalodon movie
earned some serious coin at the box
office drawing 528 million dollars
worldwide
against its 130 million dollar budget
and
maybe that's not really so surprising
after all it's basically a movie about
jason statham going to war with a
gigantic
shark who doesn't want to see that well
after audiences went into a feeding
frenzy for the film plans for a sequel
were almost immediately set into motion
in october 2020 warner brothers
confirmed that of all people the
critically acclaimed thriller filmmaker
ben wheatley will be helming the
sharktastic sequel
nobody's really sure what the plot will
be but since the meg is actually based
on a series of books by steve alton
the sequel might well draw on the next
novel which involves an even
bigger shark as well as the giant
crocodile-like beast
known as the kronosaurus in 2007 disney
captivated audiences with
enchanted a princess story with a twist
in which the animated princess giselle
accidentally tumbles into real world
live-action
new york city although gisele eventually
found her happy ending with single dad
robert that didn't stop
talk of a sequel from spinning soon
after the film's release
while the sequel titled disenchanted was
slow getting off the ground the
production is now full steam ahead
and will be premiering exclusively on
disney plus
in 2016 hairspray director adam shankman
was brought on board to direct the movie
and he confirmed in 2019 that he's still
attached to the production
the script for disenchanted is said to
take place 10 years after the first film
following giselle as she questions her
happily ever after
and inadvertently shakes things up in
both the real world
and the animated kingdom of andalysia
disney has confirmed that amy adams will
return for the sequel
and while patrick dempsey hasn't been
officially announced as a cast member he
has told entertainment tonight that he'd
happily be involved just so long as the
sequel can live up to the magic
of the original nearly a quarter century
after the release of the first screen
movie
a fifth installment in the deliciously
self-aware horror franchise has wrapped
filming
and is headed to theaters in 2022 stars
courtney cox and david arquette have
appeared in all
four previous scream installments and
both officially signed on for the fifth
film in 2020.
although cox and arquette are divorced
in real life their characters should
theoretically still be married in the
films
marley shelton who played judy hicks in
scream 4 will also be returning as will
neve campbell
who played protagonist sydney prescott
in all four prior scream films
although campbell's casting was never
officially announced by campbell or the
studio
her involvement was confirmed when kevin
williamson tweeted a photo of himself
alongside campbell and cox announcing
the end of filming
in a caption williamson wrote i'm
thrilled to be reunited with neve
courtney david and marley and to be
working alongside a new filmmaking team
and incredible cast of newcomers that
have come together to continue west's
legacy with the upcoming relaunch of the
franchise that i hold
so dear to my heart see you in theaters
january 2022
in 2015 mad max fury road reinvigorated
the long dormant mad max
franchise offering a thrilling new spin
on george miller's post-apocalyptic
action series
casting tom hardy as max and shifting
the focus to charlize theron's rage
fueled imperator furiosa
fury road wowed audiences and critics
alike with many
now considering it one of the best
action films of
all time so it seemed that a sequel was
pretty much inevitable
and sure enough five years after fury
road roared into theaters
two follow-up films are in the works one
is a direct sequel to fury road while
the other is a prequel
centered around a younger furiosa the
sequel which has been given the working
title
mad max the wasteland was reportedly
greenlit by warner brothers
in early 2020 and while the movie will
follow the further exploits of max
furiosa herself isn't set to return of
course furiosa will
bring back the character but thrawn
won't be making an appearance in that
film either
director george miller said that much as
he loved theron's performance in fury
road
he doesn't have enough faith in de-aging
technology to allow therin to reprise
her role for the prequel
instead the younger furiosa will be
played by anya taylor joy
who will be joined by mcu star chris
hemsworth and
emmy-winning launchmen actor yaya
abdulmatin ii
in undisclosed roles however their
characters have likely existed in
miller's head since before the previous
film
since he developed origin stories for
every character while prepping fury
road even writing an entire screenplay
for furiosa in the process
in an act of divine providence or maybe
just hollywood nostalgia it looks like
sister mary clarence will be donning her
habits once again
in late 2020 whoopi goldberg announced
that sister act 3
is finally in the works after years of
being told that there was no interest in
a prequel
the film which will premiere on disney
plus was confirmed by disney at their
2020 investor day event
goldberg will be returning as both star
and producer with tyler perry also
coming on board to produce
released in 1992 the first sister act
saw goldberg play dolores von cartier
a lounge singer who goes into witness
protection at a convent after witnessing
a killing
there in the guise of a nun named sister
mary clarence dolores transforms the
convent's humdrum choir
into an upbeat musical sensation sister
act got a sequel in 1993 with sister act
2
back in the habit which found dolores
stepping in as a music teacher for a
group of low-achieving students at a
catholic school
and while goldberg hasn't dropped any
hints about the plot of sister act 3
it's safe to assume that dolores will be
likely giving a lackluster singing group
a powerful musical makeover it hasn't
yet been confirmed whether the recurring
cast members from the previous movies
will be returning
but goldberg herself seems keen to bring
them back into the fold
so we're working diligently to try to
figure out how to get every get the gang
together
while hocus pocus failed to make much of
a splash when it was first released in
1993 it has since gathered a cult
following as a halloween staple
the film follows a group of kids who
accidentally resurrect a trio of sisters
on halloween
300 years after their execution in 1693.
while details on the sequel remain
scarce
original hocus pocus writer mick garris
has suggested that although he himself
is not involved
he's under the impression that original
stars bette midler kathy najimi and
sarah jessica parker are set to return
those three have indeed all expressed
interest in the movie so now that hocus
pocus ii has been officially confirmed
by disney
it would be surprising if they didn't
make at least a brief appearance
hocus pocus 2 is expected to debut on
disney plus sometime in the not too
distant future
released in 2010 david fincher and aaron
sorkins the social network
earned tremendous critical acclaim and
won three oscars for its screenplay
editing and score now a decade later
sorkin is eager to return to the story
of mark zuckerberg's tech empire
this time looking into what facebook has
become and the role it plays in modern
politics
speaking to mtv's happy sad confused
podcast about the possibility of a
social
network sequel sorkin said i do want to
see it
and producer scott rudin wants to see it
people have been talking to me about it
because of what we've discovered
is the dark side of facebook although
sorkin and ruden seem to be on board
there's one thing that could still stand
in the way of the social network too
becoming a reality
a commitment from director david fincher
working explained
i will only write it if david directs it
if billy wilder came back from the grave
and said he wanted to direct it i'd say
i'd only do it with david
in addition to jesse eisenberg the
social network starred a number of other
talented young actors and although it's
safe to assume that the social network
too
would see eisenberg return to his role
there's no knowing which of his fellow
social network cast members
might make an appearance in the sequel
after the massive commercial success of
disney's lion king remake
it seemed like only a matter of time
until the sequel was announced but the
follow-up's director is more of a
surprise because
this time academy award-winning writer
and director barry jenkins will be
sitting in the director's chair
jenkins won't be writing the lion king 2
but will be working from a script by
jeff nathanson
who penned the first movie while no
specific details of the plot have been
revealed
deadline reports that the story will
further explore the mythology of the
characters including mufasa's origin
story
although the lion king 2 seems like an
outlier in jenkins filmography
which includes movies such as moonlight
and if beale street could talk
the director seems excited about working
on the sequel in a statement
jenkins said having the opportunity to
work with disney on expanding this
magnificent tale of friendship love and
legacy
while furthering my work chronicling the
lives and souls of folk within the
african diaspora
is a dream come true during disney's
2020 investor day event the studio
reaffirmed that a fifth installment in
the iconic indiana jones franchise is on
the way
and will once again star indy himself
harrison ford
at 78 years old ford will likely be
retiring his trademark whip and fedora
by the end of indiana jones 5.
although the studio hasn't yet indicated
whether the film will see him pass the
baton to a younger generation
or close out the franchise altogether
[Music]
it's the mileage james mangold is
sitting in the director's chair for the
new movie and if anybody
knows how to bring the legacy of a
beloved action hero to a dignified end
it's him mangold previously directed
2017's logan which earned him an academy
award nomination for best adapted
screenplay
and served as a thrilling and satisfying
conclusion for hugh jackman
and patrick stewart's characters while
indiana jones 5 isn't likely to skew
nearly as dark as logan fans can only
hope that it will provide a similarly
moving farewell
to everybody's favorite adventurer indy
5 hits theaters in july 2022
in october 2020 actor stephen lang
revealed on twitter that he just wrapped
filming on don't breathe 2
the sequel to the 2016 home invasion
horror thriller
in the first film lang played the
cryptically named blind man
a homeowner who finds himself the target
of a trio of small-scale burglars
unfortunately for the whippy thieves the
blind man is far more capable and
ruthless than they assume and winds up
trapping them in a deadly game of cat
and mouse
the sequel follows lange's character
several years after the home invasion as
the blind man lives in quiet isolation
with a young girl who is orphaned by a
house fire
the blind man is forced to jump back
into action when the girl is kidnapped
however and
if the first movie is any indication the
kidnappers have
no idea what they're in for after
six successful movies very loosely based
on the video game series of the same
name
resident evil is finally getting a
proper origin story jumping back to the
events of the earliest games in the
series
this standalone resident evil prequel
will start cayo scotillario as claire
redfield
hannah john cammon as jill valentine
robbie amellas chris redfield
tom hopper as albert wesker evan jogia
as leon kennedy
and neil mcdonough as william birkin the
film will be written and directed by
johannes roberts who said of his
approach to the film
with this movie i really wanted to go
back to the original first two games
and recreate the terrifying visceral
experience i had when i first played
them
whilst at the same time telling a
grounded human story about a small dying
american town that feels both relatable
and relevant to today's audiences
robert's approach is likely to be a
significant departure from the previous
six films which were all directed by
paul w
s anderson no release date has been
announced for the resident evil prequel
but
filming began in october of 2020 and
it's expected to hit screens sometime in
2021
more than three decades after the
original troop beverly hills hit
theaters in 1989
a sequel is in the works from israeli
filmmaker oren zegman in her featured
directorial debut
the original troop beverly hills film
starred shelley long as a pampered
housewife on the brink of divorce
who sets out to prove to her family that
she is capable of more than they think
by becoming a wilderness girl's den
mother
there's no word yet on whether the
original cast will return
or even what the sequel is about but ava
fry's whose real-life experiences
inspired the events of the first movie
is back on board as executive producer
indicating that the sequel could also
draw from some part of her life although
nothing official has yet been announced
while the main toy story narrative
appears to have been wrapped up by the
end of toy story 4
it seems that pixar aren't ready to say
goodbye to the franchise just yet
disney announced during their 2020
investor day event that everyone's
favorite space ranger
buzz lightyear would be getting his own
feature film which will arrive in
theaters
june 17th 2022 but light year won't be
your typical spin-off instead of
following the tim allen voiced character
from the toy story films
light year will follow a different buzz
lightyear voiced by
mcu star chris evans after pixar tweeted
that the movie will be
the definitive story of the original
buzz lightyear
evans followed their announcement up
with a clarification of his own saying
and just to be clear this isn't buzz
lightyear the toy
this is the origin story of the human
buzz lightyear that the toy
is based on basically this is the movie
on which the buzz lightyear toys are
based
expect plenty of sci-fi heroics
thrilling space action
and hopefully an appearance from this
guy i'll never give in
you killed my father no buzz
i am your father
in a normal year a movie like the war
with grandpa probably wouldn't have
delivered an especially notable
performance at the box office
but in 2020 when many theaters were
operating at extremely limited capacity
the movie was a surprising success
since it was basically one of the only
ones anybody could actually see
still that's apparently enough to
warrant a sequel starring robert de niro
alongside an all-star cast the war with
grandpa fall is a kid who is upset about
having to give up his room to his
grandfather and decides to wage war in
order to reclaim it
although the film ends with the two in a
better place the sequel will apparently
revisit the family when grandpa proposes
to his girlfriend
and needs to meet her family from london
while there's no word on a release date
just yet
we can only hope that when it finally
does release it will be under
far less harrowing circumstances
although a gi joe spin-off titled snake
eyes was delayed until 2021 due to the
coronavirus pandemic
that hasn't stopped paramount from
moving forward with yet another gi joe
sequel
while no plot or casting details for the
third gi joe film have been confirmed
back in 2018 it was reported that the
title would be gi joe ever vigilant
and that it would start dwayne johnson
reprising his role from gi joe
retaliation
of course at the time that those details
were announced mission impossible ghost
protocol writers josh applebaum and
andre nemik were also attached to write
the script
which is no longer the case with the
script changing hands it's very possible
that none of the other previously
announced details are still the case but
we'll likely find out soon enough having
announced that the absurdly successful
transformers franchise
will be stepping in a new direction
paramount are eyeing up creed 2 director
stephen caple jr to helm the next movie
in the franchise
capel will be working from a script
written by joby harold who was
responsible for the screenplay for king
arthur legend of the sword
and will be serving as a writer for the
upcoming obi-wan kenobi series at disney
plus
while a deal hasn't closed quite yet
production insiders told deadline that
cable was the top
choice among studio executives and
producers although paramount hasn't yet
revealed anything definitive about the
plot or characters for transformer 7
producer lorenzo d bonaventura
previously revealed that the studio
wasn't interested in developing a direct
sequel to the last knight
and that the next transformers film
won't be picking up where that one left
off
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]
you